Salve signora come sta?
Bene, e mia mamma le manda i saluti
Maryna è sopra?
Allora io vado... con permesso
Bella Ro'! Come stai?
Passate le morroidi?
Hai usato la crema che ti avevo consigliato? Lo sapevo, lo sapevo. Quella funziona sempre mia mamma é na vita che la usa
Mary lo sai che ti voglio bene e voglio solo che tu sia felice
E quindi non voglio mancarti di rispetto oppure offenderti, però secondo me
quel ragazzo non fa per te
Dovresti trovare qualcuno che ti meriti di più,  che abbia il tuo stesso stile di vita, che sia più maturo... ecco più maturo, non credi?
Oh ma allora non ci arrivi proprio, ceh sei de coccio.Quante volte te lo devo dire, si è fatto tutta la scuola, sta collezionano
ragazze come tu collezioni tinte labbra cioè vuoi le  corna stile Malefica, vuoi questo? No ma allora continua così
continua a farti del male, continua a soffrire per un pezzo di merda quando la tua migliore amica è da dieci anni che ti dice che lo devi lasciare, che lo devi lasciar perdere
ma te no, perché ti entra da qui e ti esce di lì, allora sai cosa ti dico? Non mi chiedere più consigli perché
io mi sono stufata, basta non ti voglio più parlare
Giù hai fame? Facciamo merenda?
No grazie... non ho tanta fame.
Allora...
merenda...
questo...
poi possiamo prendere
e poi le caramelle.
Arrivo!
Mary, io vorrei tanto dormire qua... però non so se mia mamma mi lascia
forse se magari la provi a chiamare tu, magari la convinci
...va bene adesso
prova a chiamarla...La chiami?!
Salve signora, sono Marina
l'amica di Giulia, ehm
volevo sapere se poteva
magari dormire dormire da me questa sera
Stiamo a casa ovviamente non usciamo...ehm se vuole le passo mia mamma così... così è sicura
Ma tu cosa ci fai qua?! Hai voglia amo, sono qua da tre ore, ho guardato uomini e donne con tua mamma,
ho fatto i compiti a tuo fratello, ho portato sotto il cane. ah rimango a dormire. No vabbe adorooo!
Mary, mi hanno detto di non dirtelo, non insistere, ho dato la mia parola a Giada.... dai veramente non mi far litigare con lei
Ceh ma ti rendi conto? Mi ha detto di non dirtelo!
A parte che, voglio dire nessuno si deve permettere di parlarti dietro, ma poi voglio dire, me lo vieni a dire a me, alla tua migliore
amica?! Cioe ma ce la fai? No guarda veramente, na massa di ignoranti.
Ma Giuli stai piangendo? Io?! No, figurati se piango per un film dai...
stai scherzando?
ma non può morire lui!
Giù come sto? Benissimo... perfetta,come sempre
Grazie, allora usciamo.
Amo come sto? Amo cos'è sto schifo..?! Ma non penserai mica di uscire così! Per me è no, vatti subito a cambiare, così non esci.
Ok...
Mary...
Senti, è bellissimo... me lo...
Me lo puoi prestare così lo metto sabato sera..?
Davvero?!
grazie, ti amo! Ti prometto che ne avrò cura, te lo porto in tintoria e lunedì mattina, a scuola, te lo restituisco.
Grazie!Bellissimo!
Ciao amo a domani! Ciao...
No scusa dove stai andando con i miei vestiti?
A casa! Con i miei vestiti?!
Eh li sto portando a casa, mi servono per il weekend. Dai amo mi servono, ti prego! Quando me li restituisci?
Ma si amo...dai stai tranquilla poi te li do, ciao